greetings all you beautiful people Joey
Diaz here welcome to my flavours world
it's a beautiful day to be alive here in
California
really [ __ ] is I usually get up
really early I'd go a little right you
know I even drive my wife and train
whatever this morning I didn't get late
start I woke up a [ __ ] 7:15 and I
didn't go to yoga we go tonight on my
wife I like taking a walk around my
neighborhood just to see what's cracking
but I just don't I tell people all the
time I just don't have animals at the
house
I have animals all around the [ __ ]
neighborhood
but the animals that really got me with
these little cats live over here
his name is biggie where's biggie
where's b'fer biggie
where's binky I haven't seen him in days
where's my baby this guy here is my
buddy
my first move to his navel by the year
where's my biggie he had a partner in
crime a girl but then she got sick and
they took her in somebody adopted and
he's always left
that's my biggie right there biggie
come on the shape-up
hi biggie come in be there this is my
boy I see I'm like dr. [ __ ] doodle
see people it's nice this guy gives me a
nice little greeting in the morning I
play with him you name it big
come here baby come it big come on
Sunday
this guy's a special little cats hello
big we got friends yeah big baby that
face he's one of my neighborhood
soldiers this guy would be there for me
no matter what looking he's a cute
little boy he lives out here there's a
father's house they feed him I came from
treat from time to time he used to be
the neighborhood tough guy
but he got neutered and now he's [ __ ]
gentle Jim Biggie's a street cat rat his
instincts
completely different a month the ones
that live in my house but he still
reacts to love you doughnuts how you pat
him how you touch him you know he's
acquired a trust with me cats are a
weird [ __ ] a lot of people on the big
cat I think it's cuz their insecurities
they can't control them the way you know
dogs come right over to you cats live on
their own [ __ ] times and that's what
I respect cuz in a way that's the way I
[ __ ] live Who am I to judge these
little [ __ ] but this guys are
this is
is a good guy say hello say hello
Joey Diaz here mad [ __ ] flavors
world tonight I'm at the YMCA check it
out
am i behind me like a punching man you
have to stand up [ __ ] dummy I don't
go over five foot two and you got the
[ __ ] kicking pose and a couple of
bikes the whole thing goes down in there
but out here is right come because half
the time I come here [ __ ] blitz throw
a little be the same you know SAS
easiest way the [ __ ] work out of here
fat dude smoking them you forget what
the [ __ ] you're doing you walk out of
here looking like [ __ ] Iron Man I'm
saying he can move but this is it this
is the big deal I get joint crunch one
of those [ __ ] jams and wear my little
tight shorts and talk to people little
[ __ ] wants a dude I come in here smoke
I'm three [ __ ] numbers deep the last
day I was this some guy asking me
[ __ ] questions I have the high power
I got you know Zeppelin whatever the
[ __ ] I listened to by the way this is
the way I'm seeing it all goes down here
for yoga
but I really can't do yoga with the
camera because I'm focused on the camera
I really got to be focused on my
breathing the whole point while I got
the [ __ ] chakras but this is where it
goes down Yoga is over with my girl
Madison was a tremendous class my shirt
or anything like that but now we got to
make way cuz the Zumba people coming in
here you know I'm saying that's when it
gets ugly in this wears these $30.00
they come in here they jump up and down
they still [ __ ] talk on as they do it
all him saying but anyway yoga was
tremendous today look at my giant shirt
it's all whacked up I'm ready to rock
here my girl Madison put the white blue
that's my yoga mat wait stay black bad
flavor here my flavors world William
flight jumper walking we got my main man
here
sensing savage it was so this one I'm
willing to my eyeballs
that cookie senators all over the shout
now he put by zina my eyes they just
sizzle like The Exorcist they threw the
water on it was saying spoken thank you
sir
mad flavor world coming at you both
thank you sir you're a gentleman and a
scholar what's your name
Adams the man asleep playboy pyro
hi bro ace to wrestle professional big
paw paw good used to wrestle
professionally for work organization
why'd they call United Federation
there's no money in the independent
level why they call you pyro Oh
is it a mix part of your
real life into your care
and you're in the fire
what I'm saying
and their search of people with samples
on this guy's a diagram saying what I'm
talking about is it nice to be on map
flavor world is what you pump it to see
kind kindred souls as they say
greediness you filthy animal Joey Diaz
here I got the robe on and finally fits
for years I got a robe in the room
they'd have a [ __ ] fit what good is
it now I'm sitting here likely like Ben
Gazzara and [ __ ] Capone you know I'm
trained but I'm in Milwaukee
check out the view day I got two things
I got my little potato chips I got my TV
they're gonna my briefcase and get it
got a split
I got a little shower there or most
important I'm with you little freak
filthy animals you're I'm saying Joey
Diaz here Wisconsin tomorrow night the
Pabst Theater Sunday the flights gonna
be beautiful right thank you for being
part of my world it's your world now
[ __ ] stay black coming to the
stage when the bat is stuffy comments
marking play the UNC the [ __ ] podcast
my brother mr. Joe Rogan
hello on my flavor world
Joey Diaz here representing math flavor
world and [ __ ]
I would do it yes
Germany
that's mad flavor well you [ __ ]
better tune in is how we doing where's
the reaper [ __ ] still at the airport
take a look at these [ __ ] pounds yeah
it's like the ugly parade here
I just put on the camera too late you
should have seen the crew that [ __ ]
came by I like some chick that look like
she died and came back to life some guy
with a Boston [ __ ] Red Sox hat off
the Boston Red Sox seen this guy he'd
[ __ ] pick up and move and go to
Bulgaria
for example
this is a spot there you want to see
some [ __ ] freaks come to LAX [ __ ]
it was a great weekend like to thank all
you people are coming out to the Pabst
Theater somebody gave me some hash
candies a black coming three I love you
guys thank you
tremendous stay black